[Music]
amy you there
okay well amy didn't want to talk to her
she didn't like us uh and that's fine
we'll go to the blinds.com amy are you
there
hey sorry it was on me oh it's not a
problem how can we help you today
okay i made a very stupid car mistake
and i entered into a lease three years
ago three and a half years ago
and i was married at the time and didn't
know everything all the ins and outs of
the lease
long story short fast forward three
years
after trying to get out of it a couple
times
i am over my mileage and over nine
thousand dollars worth
so yeah so i can't sit down and cry i
don't have to stand up and do something
about it
that's right so i i think my options are
and you have to tell me where i'm wrong
and leading the right direction
either that out uh
borrow the loss that was the option one
would be buy
out number two would be to go borrow
what up the nine or ten thousand dollars
pay it and then get into a cheaper car
or three the dealership
is uh one is looking at putting me in
one of their smaller
newer cars um enrolling
over the the law you'll be the same
payment yeah
yeah and you you're as you talk through
the options you're absolutely right so
tell me this what's the card that you
leased
it is a uh infinity 2x60 okay and and
how how how old what year was it
is it 2017. okay 60. and so what was the
your your what's your dollar amount that
you owe them because of the mileage
uh nine thousand dollars for the mileage
so nine 000
okay um all right so talk to me here
what's your household income
uh by myself i bring in 72
about 72 and a half 73 okay
and for five more years i'll get
thirteen hundred dollars in child
support
okay how many kids do you have i have
one and she's nineteen
okay all right and what other debts do
you have amy
uh my home own my home well i have a
mortgage on and i pay 8.50 a month
okay how much what's the balance on what
you owe
i owe 145 000 on my home and i could
sell it today for about 2 15. okay
what else do you go um
i have two credit cards and i only i pay
330
a month on that and then my car and
that's it okay the credit cards how much
do you owe on one or the biggest credit
card
the biggest credit card is uh
7 000 and i owe um 500 on the other one
okay all right all right i'm trying to
get a feel for where you are from a debt
standpoint
uh and and as i look at this i don't
like the rollover
okay i don't want them taking that
dollar amount the 9 000 that you owe and
putting that on top of something else
uh that's going to create a headache
okay so that's that's kind of like the
three card monty you remember that card
game where they move it you try to find
the hidden cart i don't like that the
other option is
do you have nine thousand dollars
sitting anywhere
i do but it's for my child's school
it's not for me we're paying out of
pocket for her school
and that in scholarship so that would
make me feel like i'm stealing from her
okay no i understand i understand i just
think the biggest thing is is you taking
a look
at you know go talk to a credit union uh
and try to see if you can get a
short-term loan uh to be able to attack
and pay that off
uh and i mean okay what did they say
i did and i'm actually talking to them
this morning and they would
loan me three three percent to buy the
car
or to do a per they would call it a
personal loan for the ten thousand
which would be ten percent and i didn't
quite understand that okay that's the
only one i've checked with oh right
and what's the balance you owe on the
vehicle do you know
30 000. so that would be the purchase
price
yeah yeah so it'd be the 30 000 the
purchase price plus the 9 000 overage
correct no if i bought it out
if i choose to buy it out personally
then the 9000 is white dolls the only
place
that the 9000 would come in is if i were
to turn the vehicle in
and leave it free leave it or if i
wanted to
if i decided to go with the other option
with rolling it out to another car okay
gotcha
got you so you're essentially looking at
a vehicle that's that's around 21 000
right that's right um ah
boy oh boy i tell you i mean
go ahead um we do my daughter has a car
is paid for in full so but i have to
have access to a vehicle for my work i
have to have a reliable car
and i don't mind driving an older car
but i'm you know
yeah i mean but here's the mindset
here's what we don't want to do
we don't want to take uh we don't want
to go into 21 000
worth of debt just for you to have a
vehicle right it's a matter of having
something
that runs so it's math right do you want
to have a
21 000 problem or a 9 000 dollar problem
i'm gonna go the nine thousand dollar
problem route
uh and so utilizing that with that the
credit union and talking to them
uh turning that vehicle in get it out of
your life and then now what you have is
a savings issue
to be able to save up and get another
car uh i don't like the rollover i just
compounds the problem yeah i agree with
you hogan
i'm with you like how do we figure out
to get that nine ten thousand dollars
covered
yeah and get that over and then get out
of it now here's the thing she may have
to consider
um is using some of that money to go buy
a cash car
because once she once she pays off that
turns the car in pays off the extra the
mileage
she has to have a vehicle right so i
mean with her having some money in her
her child savings account for college
you know i get it you don't want me to
feel like you're stealing from your your
daughter but at the same time you're not
stealing it's your money
that's right so you know go buy you a
nice reliable cash car
and let's figure out how do we go ahead
and pay cash uh for you for your
daughter's college as well but you know
i appreciate you calling in
amy because a lot of times we can become
so stressed
that we grab the first option and we're
not looking for the first
option we want to find the best solution
overall and that's a shift in mindset uh
talk to the credit union about that that
that shorter term loan pay this thing
off turn in this vehicle get it out of
your life
and you live and you learn no leases
we're not doing that you're going to
save up cash buy a car for cash
and upgrade over time got to slow down
think clearly
and do it the right way this is the dave
ramsey show